- Magnus let's Carmelina concierge drama
smoke over stuffy fizzy tune gasps
obsession
Thomas Monaco says his job requires a
passion for service as head concierge at
the ritz-carlton Berlin he tries to meet
guests every need from restaurant
recommendations to theater tickets or
ensuring a handwritten poem reaches its
recipient he makes it possible
once you have signed this mint humble
concierge is my dream job you learn
something new every day about the city
about the job itself about how the hotel
works about guests and people woman
there's so much when I started doing
this many years ago I had no idea it
would be my dream job but now it's
become that and yes I'm glad to do this
with my life monk OHS shift begins at
6:30 in the morning the smart uniform
sets him apart the born-and-bred
Berliner went straight from high school
to training in a hotel he was appointed
head concierge at the 5-star Hotel in
2005 responsible not only for the guests
but also for a dozen pages and Porter's
any questions mr. Furr do we have an
event today no then I wish you all a
nice day and lots of fun and hanging him
talk in 2010 he won the title of
Germany's concierge of the year the
application included an anecdote about
his attention to guests guests the
youngest and we had regulars who came
here and the father had unfortunately
forgotten his little daughters luggage
and all her toys and clothes were inside
at the concierge desk we decided to be
proactive and got her some cuddly toys a
teddy bear and a lion and we sent them
up to the room along with some milk and
cookies to decline of understand sir
damn it's Caixin on mesh of Samoa
chicken
the ritz-carlton is located on potsdamer
platz one of Berlin's main tourism hubs
more and more people visit the German
capital each year in 2013 there were
around eleven point three million making
Berlin one of the most popular cities in
Europe and there are more than 500
hotels competing for their custom the
luxury segment is particularly
competitive Berlin is home to some 27
5-star hotels an excellent concierge is
critical to success in putting on the
same Canon semaphore : understood
ultimately it's not rooms we're selling
but service guests nowadays don't when
you look at the amenities of a room
because in this segment we're all
playing in the same league so it's
really a matter of personal and
individual service that's how you can
stand out from the competitors from it
without undue shows this guest wants to
rent a movie the concierge offers quite
a collection to choose from everything
from comedies to classics
the job of a concierge is to make the
impossible possible it's an essential
service to guests at a luxury hotel even
if to some people a concierge in his
uniform looks like a relic of the past
the best knowledge in what I recently
heard a lecture where someone said them
have to be better than the Internet and
he was absolutely right
and that can only be achieved with the
personal touch and values that you are
dear to and pass on Thomas Mungo is
dedicated to his profession after a
nine-hour shift at the hotel he uses his
free time to test a New Berlin
restaurant for a brief moment the
perfect host becomes a guest himself